his yin space
is there that's where you have to enter
inside
[Music]
okay so he goes i enter
here's here i'm grabbing it with an
angle of incidence
i'm not grabbing it out of space
my hand my arm is there and i'll find it
at the end
just like mikyo just like when you do
ego you find the wrist at the end you
find the joe at the end okay
so i'm moving and then
this joe don't go down because his
balance isn't there
so use the joe just like you do any
cocky projection
it has to go through his through his
center
[Music]
it's out out and down
or you're going like this
i don't doubt if it could happen okay
but it has a lot to do with him his over
penetration
you get it so we're not doing that
when he when he comes in i'm going to
get a body lock
here in front here in front
this way okay so i'm going to just show
it
so you can see what what i'm doing to
his body so this
this arm is going to tighten by going
into the inward spiral
and use the hip so watch watch what
happens to his stance
so it's no different joe please
i'm coming here whoa i'm not going to do
a momentum throwing cookie hole
you're going to have a body lock
so again got got this part
now my hip goes in
so it's not this
because athletes run out
it's body
then to that since i have a joke
i use the joke okay so he's in
i'm going to get the lock get myself in
place
start the walk you see then
out once he goes into the kazushi
the in space opens up i'm the joe indies
this is different
different and uk likes that way better
because you can't control themselves
and the other way your kids got to work
on
not getting their head hit because
they're going okay
so usually you leave the arm out
you just have a cosmetic arm or you want
to grab
make sure it's palm up
palm down okay
that's what lowers his head okay so just
eye humping
i'm going to do juji knocking and a lot
of you think
you're breaking the arm i'm not breaking
the arm i'm actually going to
this arm is going to go like this and
i'm going to end up on the inside
where there is no joint and that's
that's what i take to the ground
just taking that down whoa
don't just stay up stay up stay up stay
up
stay up stay up
so that's a that's a momentum roll i'll
show you the difference
that's a ball hey
this is a fall watch your leg hi sing
that's what that's going to throw you
right here there's no leg trap hey
so there's no roll
so you just walk that's it but this is
going to take you down
that's a roll again
get up you're just gonna go
down that's it
so where you can go down if you can go
down
you don't need to roll if you don't need
to roll
what don't roll
don't leave this out and you're gonna
feel the downwardness of this
different this is different you feel it
on your joint yes
no downwards around your joint
okay let's try to go so that's what
you're doing on the first
this move right here i'm going to
start the descent this one
that's what you're doing it's not
accelerating
i need to get him in the front inward
position you're going to step
in right try it again
i need to get his head low so his hip
can go out
now that to do that
i have to get on the inside of his arm
the inside
let's go to the joe stay there you
already know this technique
this is where you do your songkills and
things like that
okay so he tries to stand up
you see it's not the obvious
joint on joint okay
so this arm's not cosmetic nor going
that way
it has to start the descent so i get
that curve
let go right i help get this leg there
rewind the film back
by pushing it out
so head takes weight off of that leg
and i push it out
do you get the body lock oh
this is going to go down in
push it's not up to him whether he rolls
or not
okay go so uh
same technique but in principle but
different
okay so remember a guy it's very common
when you
when people are searching they they
don't know how to pull the rifle in
uh when they have tight corners it's
very common very very common
that they're tying incorrectly
so this one he's walking i'm going to
bring him into that same circle
so this time last time we did this hand
this time i use this town but i'm going
to be in that safe circle
so if i'm not gonna go here whoa
i have to get inside the same circle so
boom inside the center
boom
then we're going to take advantage of
this
this leverage right there
do the same thing boom this way
okay
this way
you want boom
then you do the same injury
the part you pull down is that that
gives you your head tilt
adds to it in
same push through the center on the
right
make sure this is going around you so
that you enter inside of it
hey hey